hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim
okay we got Lydia here we got these dead
Khajiit here and we're going into the
Dwemer depths to try to find something
something I don't know what ah are their
tails still moving that's freaky anyway
but argonians died their tails today
dead oh I hear fire is that just steam
pipes why were those cuz you'd even down
here how did they wow wow wow wow wow no
I said no no yep handy isn't hurt she's
knit you did not hurt at all
elevating platform I get it yeah it is
come on now let me up let me up
whoop better send me up up up up up up
up come on get down get down
ah yeah now uh do as I command
go up there we go whoops it easy What's
Up Morgan little kid
bad flawless emerald bring up this
square all right now back down this is
interesting
someone said that one the Dwemer were
dwarves oh hello hello little spider
Freddie to die
oh hello another one wants to join the
party okay I got enough for the Mafia
yeah silver for guard um I must be
getting close to where I need to be
right right right
I don't know where that is I see a
marker off in the distance but I'm not
going towards
well dick see it doesn't count I didn't
see it seems weird bashing me people the
sword nothing down here
let's go Lydia hi I am careful you'll be
careful Wampus fam um again I don't know
where the pretty crackers going another
one
I don't see any
oh hello two-handed skill I'm so skilled
Lydia why did you change what
you saw me and my two-handed awesomeness
and then you decided to join the party
talk about right
all right what have we got here jump
over that that it's not really much of a
trap if you can't push me off hello
Gilbert Oh
medical track I do need more between
skills then again I haven't been new on
in terms of combat I don't know how far
I am in the game
ah the am a naman no no curry the
eminent ol curry the aminal curry I
don't know I didn't get a good enough
look at it either way that's where I'm
supposed to be Lydia Lydia Lydia really
Lydia Lydia it wasn't that hard just a
door Lydia is just a door hello buddy
get ready to die oh that's that you want
to live too bad Lydia
oh no no big guy there to die didn't
hurt welcome new [ __ ] that actually does
hurt dare we go down decorative
decorative Dwemer strut that's just what
I need
oh hello you want to fight - you want
meth with me nope no one know where I'm
going
xx eggs for what
when two full Magica told us of oil in
the ground that I probably light on fire
if I was up magic-user lenio
that woman I swear
why do I put up
oh whoa whoa whoa ambush
what level ahh I'll save that actually
there might be a boss fight coming up
who knows I could always use a full heal
on-demand hello pretty
hello goodbye didn't hurt buses at I
need better I need better swords I need
to get better in blacksmithing and then
I need to get better in well a better
weapon it's only it's only steel I mean
this goes to iron than steel and then
everything else
I'd like two handed swords I like
two-handed swords don't tell me you
don't like two-handed swords - ah
seriously like the egg sacs - little
Souls can they take the spider souls
from I don't know it was something there
you down there anyway it's a good jump
but I don't want to
alright what's through here oh hello
play click like a mouse it's on the best
what if these workers even do it what's
the point
they don't seem to have much of a
purpose other than dying where the heck
is Lydia Lydia yeah whoa what what okay
Wow which is like boom alright then
that's cool
um nothing pulling going thank you for
here oh god I don't think I can do this
[ __ ] it is an expert but then again I am
so ro click got it log about on the
based on the best horror war ving helmet
sting was that guy holding the lock room
off really is that just supposed to be
irony oh boy Master oh boy those dopes
no one saw that
oh god that the area is gonna be so
small I'm not even gonna be able to find
it let alone get it I stopped sleeping I
was wrong when I go through all my
pictures time to get this [ __ ] I swear I
don't even know where the point of entry
is just start going radial Direction
[ __ ]
ah ah found you [ __ ]
ah so close
[ __ ] I can get this guy's I can get it
yes hmm
yes I was just saying I was just saying
anyone yes all right
that's excited and it excite I get any
Thord
I get a new sword mmm mmm mmm only one
point damage more but that's because not
like sharpened or anything hmm
mmm yeah yeah
all right now that I got my dog yes
golden oh yeah but maybe not golden I
need to get down there somehow I guess I
just jumped
whoops-a-daisy throne ow
whoa
feeling not moving what's this guy doing
out here or this lady sorry lady I know
you're a lady
hi I know you're a lady have you been
shot by Palmer arrows but I don't know
how you got down here um Lydia really
Lydia you're fine
did you break a leg or something you
okay Lydia maybe I should be more whoa
where'd you come from suck down some
Ahmad dwarven sword yeah I wasn't a
euphemism room Oh give me no hey get
back here here here yeah beau no okay
Baumer whoa hello you want to join the
party too warm can't get some of this
you didn't whoa here ow
I'm poisoned I need to eat baked
potatoes bread more bread
goat cheese wheel good real chicken
breast leeks just shove all of this food
into my face hmm delicious like a worst
investment of hating a food I've ever
seen in my life
there's a lot of these douches
I gotta be careful they actually hurt
well that was a trap miss me ah you dick
you dick I'm gonna getcha I'll getcha oh
[ __ ] I got you boss I I follow through
with my promises
oh is this up close the gap and then you
go down and then you go off the mountain
well damn it
you just had to land on that platform
you just had to you son of a [ __ ] I'm
gonna murder you
oh you're dead oh that's okay - that's
good and there's a stream of fire why
Dodd's log about
glamor lever Dwemer Dwemer Dwemer Dwemer
what does he fall mar doing in the
Dwemer they like the descendants of the
Dwemer are now dead
all gone Oh dick three Lydia take care
of them till my fus-ro-dah party Becca
what am i doing what am i doing
Gaia [ __ ] hell I didn't go anywhere
huh I'm not trying to hit you lady
thanks for taking them and this is how
you doing
it's killer Leah you okay are you okay
Lydia are you okay don't look so good
Lydia like come on Lydia just cuz you
got one point of health left doesn't
mean you get to laze about let's go
without a musician bleeding Crown Derby
scaly but Papa Doc
do I even know how to make a potion I
there's actually a lot of ingredients
that I have that I haven't eaten to find
out what's going on with them I want to
be able to make health potions I just
drank Dwemer oil that cannot be good for
me
garlic Chive I could eat a giant stone
sounds good to me
I already ate that look my alchemy is
increasing somehow by eating weird
objects that I found just lying around
there's a lot of stuff that I haven't
even see scaly for tadaa Skeever tail
fish snowberries might be good but
everything else Swamp fungal pod yeah
torch bug thorax troll fat tundra
convoyed salt and wheat okay I am just
about killed myself from all the crap
that I've gotten me see how many magic
effects her oh my lord I am so weak to
everything now
oh that's nice
also doesn't affect my fus-ro-dah just
does that
okay and I'm less effective with melee
weapons but did through all that did I
get to know how to make restore health
there it is
store doors doors now I can experiment a
bit failed of course it did
ok that's fantastic clear all right boo
boo I know there's probably a more
efficient way to do this but I don't
care is my way oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no barracks with Red Mountain flying
blue bonfire yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
ocean of restore health added get more
damnit alright whatever quit alchemy
yeah that's enough for now
at least I have some more restore health
hat no alright moving forward
hello is anybody home
hi there come through the fire perfect I
love it go back through this Lydia
Galloway all right Lydia totally did not
mean to do that trying to get these guys
burned up oh yeah Liddy tanked that [ __ ]
womp
God'll idiot you got it damn it Lydia
what good are you know good to know one
I'm sorry I didn't mean that
Oh what's this oh oh oh I don't know
whomp can't get me
got criticals drag on your block [ __ ]
any day
did you use my ISKCON force above al
[ __ ] me can't give me can't give me
oh I'm healing so much Argonian blood
[ __ ] walk oh you see teeth oh there
you are Lydia it's so good of you to
join you okay
did that hurt I don't care all right I
care no actually I don't know Lydia I
love you baby
or do I failed me for the last time
those traps down or something okay I'll
go around them easy enough who what's
all this
ah fill these ingredients all of them
hey oh alright
I guess they were cooking oh they were
just trying to live in a they were
defending their homes and I came in and
murdered them what a bastard I'm whoa
where'd you come from how you hit your
own guy oh man
so sad for you thank that [ __ ] this
is a great sort of cleave damn oh I
would like it if it
womp can't see that but I did it
murdered you good to both take that and
there we go
ooh a lever in the middle of an empty
room I wonder who am I supposed to go
here this is where I know I'll just go
up there
wait a minute I must be going in the
wrong direction
okay no that's where I came from did I
make a wrong turn somewhere oh right
through the farm I must have made a
wrong turn somewhere hang on
or maybe I am supposed to go down there
I don't know let me just go like an
elevator or something wait up here huh
no no
all right hard to tell man I mean
seriously it's really hard to tell
ah maybe I still see the marker is that
even is that marker even point oh my god
oh okay
all this just leads out this is the way
out no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no back to the animal calorie animal
cooler e and a monk laughs la sorry
Lydia saw a baby you know I love whoo
more ingredients all these
and summon we made rooms
okay is that it cool Grove cure wounds
we'll take that dead someone oops not
did not mean to take that
Valley why she named
that shackles huh yeah that person did
not fare as well as Valley I mean
they're both dead but hopefully they one
was eaten but before death or after
death not before that would be terrible
where am I where am I going
I don't even know down there please tell
me down there please tell me down there
I wished it was down there whoops yeah I
got you all did do a lot good go get him
Goggan whoo I killed one of you right
out
come on spotter what you got
ooh see that Lydia oh my god they kill
Lydia or they kill Lydia no no no no no
I didn't know Lydia could die no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no and oh you do not kill Lydia
yeah I'll be joking me damn phone calls
I'm soaked
no no no no no I did not know Lydia
could die I feel bad now I've sent her
into the fray how many times is she
almost died
ah
okay take two now Lydia you stay alive
okay not gonna let you die I'm gonna
take the brunt black Domino whoa
holy hell that guy went flying okay now
I'm in here I'm in the thick of it I
care
whoa come after me one down
yeah no one messes with Lydia no one
does
I already lost my horse who's Lydia -
not that I'm very Lydia - a horse she's
very pretty for I don't know he's not a
horse
I must be going the right direction
ah yes yes yes I am the trap don't Lydia
don't Lydia you're just trying to get
killed I swear knowledge photon
Cathedral a power attack might
staggering opponent up what's this
trap-trap Lydia dodge to travel ah
Lydia Wow that probably should have
eviscerated me seriously cut me into a
few pieces whoa whoa leveling up let's
get some more help
beggin an even 200 ooh this put
something in stamina this time I didn't
know I had to do levels
and can't do that but I can I can
actually so don't matter so spreading
intact it has double damage can't do
deep wounds yet am i doing on heavy
armor can I get something in have you
yes I can fists of Steel I only I fought
on ooh yes hi space Corps hi bunny
ah womp didn't stand a chance
mmm so great I'm so great I look torch
all right here my watch
oh yeah is the pretty son brother
anything like that
me neither Lydia how poignant of you to
say the cabin item the cabin item damn
it Juana did you copy - Owen - Kip dude
Owen do the decapitation yes yes all
right what do we got here some lever
activated with that someone down there
bring it [ __ ] the cabinet damn it oh
well good enough I bet I guess I bet I
guess I bet
just oh crap crap crap crap crap crap
that a ballista whoa big guy hello there
captain
Oh Lydia don't die Lydia come after me
bros staggered bring it [ __ ]
get away from Lydia aah
you killed Lydia Lydia what the hell you
were down [ __ ]
Lydia please stop dying I really would
rather you stay alive
let me get lips oops road eyes and doing
[ __ ] let me get a fire run iron
aw didn't hurt alright that hurt
down [ __ ] now [ __ ] [ __ ] there we go
that's more like it I really should wow
he almost killed me I didn't even see
that
ooh Centurion Dynamo core Dynamo key -
I'll shine lift not bad but I am Amos
did don't have a healing spell I do
don't I
mr. Asian yeah I do okay let me actually
put that on my bar so that I can I put
it on both right you can do wield that
and it'll be like double double
effective Wow mom
magic is low shut up tell my magic is
low I was using it
clear skies no way Barbara shorter
cooldowns
does more damage I suppose moderately
now going on
FUS ro dah come on alright this it let's
just get off hasn't there been enough
death what of course you want me to
leave just waiting for me to turn my
back so you can have all the glory for
yourself what what was that
what what what found you they're
fighting what what's happening I must
kill this [ __ ] like he was gonna win
anyway pretty face oh come on I thought
I was helping you
oh maybe yeah hang on I might have
accidentally hit her I don't know
I'm confused just waiting for you to
turn my back I'm gonna Bowl look I was
totally confused at this whole situation
I don't know what's going on okay I'm
gonna let them I'm gonna let them sort
it out Lydia's gonna get in there anyway
but who's Lydia is fighting the right
person
I mean I guess I must do cleave damage
with this thing because I'm staying out
of it if she comes after me afterwards
who would Morgan shield Lydia would love
that
whoa I am full up no room Lydia I need
to give you some [ __ ] ah what the hell
still fighting I'm coming at you I'm
coming I'm coming for you I'm coming for
you ah whoa no you stay away from Lydia
ah okay I guess you're just gonna take
me away
Lydia I got something for you thank you
are you alright Oh take that I'm gonna
put it on if you know not put it on me
take that take all of this that helmet
yeah that looks good
that looks good baby
hmm I guess you could hold on that just
don't equip it take that you can wear a
ring sure why not just that - weapons -
I have farmer huarac ones I pick that up
I'll just take that all right
anyway that's it the now okay that's all
the time I got for this episode thank
you so much for watching everyone and as
always see you in the next episode bye
bye